we've spoken about this offline
i'd love to get your thought about it
here
if i sat down for a long form in-person
conversation with the president of
russia vladimir putin
would you potentially want to call in
for a few minutes
uh to join in on a conversation with him
moderated translated by me
sure yeah sure i'd be happy to do that
you've shown interest in the russian
language
is this grounded in your interest in
history of linguistics culture
general curiosity i think it sounds cool
sounds cool now it looks cool so uh well
it's it's you know it's it's a
it takes a moment to read cyrillic
um
once you know what the sort of like
characters stand for actually
then reading russian becomes a lot
easier because there are a lot of words
that are actually the same like bank is
bank
[Laughter]
um
and uh
so find the words that are exactly the
same and now you start to understand
cyrillic yeah if you can if you can
sound it out then yeah
it's much
there's at least some commonality of
words what about the culture
you uh you love great engineering
physics there's a tradition of the
sciences there so you look at the 20th
century from rocketry so
you know some of the greatest rockets so
the space exploration has been done in
the soviet in the former soviet union
yeah so do you draw inspiration from
that history just how this culture that
in many ways i mean one of the sad
things is because of the language
a lot of it is lost to history because
it's not translated all those kinds of
because it it is in some ways an
isolated culture it flourishes within
its within its borders um yeah so do you
draw inspiration from those folks from
from the history of
science engineering there
i mean the soviet union russia and uh
ukraine as well
and uh have a really
strong history in
space flight like some of the most
advanced and impressive things in
history were done uh
you know by the soviet union um
so
um
one can cannot help but admire the
impressive rocket technology that was
developed
um
you know after the sort of fall of
soviet union the
there's the
there's much less that that that
happened um
but uh
still things are happening but it's not
not quite at the
um frenetic pace that was happening uh
before the soviet union kind of
dissolved into separate republics
yeah i mean i i you know there's
roscosmos the russian
agency um
i look forward to a time when those
countries with china are working
together uh in the united states they're
all working together maybe a little bit
of friendly competition but i think
friendly competition is good um
you know the government's so slow and
the only thing slower than one
government is a collection of
governments
so
yeah the olympics would be boring if
everyone just crossed the finishing line
at the same time yeah nobody would watch
yeah uh and and people wouldn't try hard
to
run fast and stuff so i think friendly
competition is a good thing
uh this is also a good place to give a
shout out to a video titled the entire
soviet rocket engine family tree by tim
dodd aka everyday astronaut it's like an
hour and a half it gives a full history
of soviet rockets
and people should definitely go check
out and support tim in general that guy
is super excited about the future super
excited about space flight every time i
see anything by him i just have a stupid
smile on my face because he's so excited
about stuff
yeah i love people like dad is real
really great if you're interested in
anything to do with space um he's in
terms of uh explaining
rocket technology to your average person
he's awesome the best i'd say
um
and um
i should say like the
other reason like uh
i switched us from
like rafter at one point was gonna be a
hydrogen engine
um
but hydrogen has a lot of challenges
it's very low density it's a it's a deep
cryogen so it's only liquid at a very
you know very close to absolute zero
requires a lot of insulation it's um
so it is a lot of challenges there
and
and i was actually reading a bit about
uh russian rocket engine development and
um
at least the impression i had was that
that uh or
soviet union russia and ukraine uh
primarily were
uh actually in the process of
uh switching to meth method locks
um and there were some interesting tests
and data for
isp like they were able to get like
up to like a 380 second isp with the
meth lux engine and i was like whoa okay
that's
that's actually really impressive so
um
so i think we could you could actually
get
a much lower cost like in optimizing
cost per ton to orbit cost per time to
mars um
it's uh
i think
um
methane auction is the way to go
um and i was partly inspired by the
russian work on the test stands
with method lux engines
you